yes four and because of that developers
are quickly moving from the drawing
board to creating 360 degree experiences
that truly immerse the player but we
haven't even scratched the surface well
we're beginning to see is that even the
simplest gameplay concepts are taking on
a new sense of depth and exhilaration
within the VR landscape encouraging
developers to re-examine with fresh eyes
the Wonder and delight of even the most
basic gaming experiences but up until
now many of the games have been
inherently solo experiences what excites
me is that Morpheus will be the virtual
reality platform that can best realize
the connection friends and families love
about ps4 and the ability to play
together imagine playing a Morpheus game
while forward your friends are inside
the same virtual world playing alongside
of you with dual shock fours on the
couch you can check that out you can
check out that exact experience at e3
this week and for the multiplayer
experience we're introducing Riggs
a new fresh IP developed by gorilla
Cambridge that puts you in the middle of
a futuristic 3vs3 battle arena eSports
mafia-style rigs will make its world
debut on the show floor at e3 this
project Morpheus is real if Goldman and
continues to capture the imagination of
a whole new development community from
small teams to the big publisher
partners they're all here at e3 and the
lines will be worth the wait Morpheus
like all of the entertainment features
on our platforms is a choice and adds
value and life to the hardware in this
life cycle our engineers are making it
possible to enhance system features
quickly based on gamer needs we recently
rebranded our music service to
PlayStation music and crafted a console
exclusive partnership with the biggest
brand on the planet for streaming music
Spotify the partnership was conceived
and tailored with the gamer in mind and
because of that with nearly 5 million
downloads the spot about Spotify app
holds the quickest launch adoption rate
in PlayStation history and this year we
also delivered on the promise of
playstation view one of the most
ambitious services we've created since
launching the network playstation view
is not just a streaming service it's a
complete live TV experience designed for
the gamer making it simpler and easier
to find the television they want we are
currently in New York Chicago and
Philadelphia markets and we are
launching tonight in San Francisco and
in Los Angeles
police station view continues to grow
and our content continues to get better
starting in July we will begin offering
our cart channels nationwide and will be
the first pay-tv service to allow users
to subscribe to individual channels
without the purchase of a multi-channel
bundle
PlayStation views initial a la carte
offering will launch with Showtime fox
soccer plus and a new exclusive channel
from machinima and PlayStation Plus
members can subscribe to these packages
at discounted rates we have something
very special with PS view and we look
forward to many more announcements with
a robust network comes the best place to
play and each of our recent product
innovations continues to advance our
vision for being that place as you've
seen tonight we're committed to bringing
the biggest titles and the best
experiences to PlayStation